last year the Debian clown he was traded
by the Houston Texans welcome to
franchise tag to the Seattle Seahawks
his deal with Seattle included the
commitment that he won't beat tags so
he's going to hit the market so is he
gonna hit the road from Seattle the
Seahawks would like to keep him but
there are other teams in the mix
reportedly the Giants and the Colts and
he told OC and Anderson the VSP NF
depending the last year in Seattle and
seeing how they do things I would
definitely like to return however I'm
also open to new opportunities if it
comes down to that
here's the challenge with today being
clown and he's got this reputation and
it's a reality he's an incredibly gifted
player he disrupts the play even though
the stats may not show it he would be
one of the leaders in what Sims calls
the f up the place that when he's
healthy he's incredible the Monday night
game against the 49ers one of the best
games of his career but then he has a
sports hernia and what are you paying
for what are you getting from Jadeveon
Clowney you're getting a lot of promise
you're getting a lot of potential but
how much production he actually getting
that's my concern for whoever pays
Davian clowny big cap well it's it's a
fair concern to throw out there but that
parentheses right there that's on the
screen turn 27 this month he just turned
27 so it's rare to get a guide like this
in thin like true free agent fashion
because a talented player like this
usually gets franchise tagged a bunch of
times or signs a long-term deal with the
team that drafts him so if you're
looking around and a lot of times when
it comes to free agency
I think teams overspend for guys that
might be over the hill or guys that
aren't gonna have their best production
and a new team this is one of those rare
cases where you can get a guy who should
be just entering his prime you know what
I mean 27 28 29 those should be prime
prime years I he's gonna get paid a lot
of money I don't know if he's gonna stay
with the Seahawks but when you when you
factor in the age I know what you're
saying with the health concerns but I
think teens will look past it knowing
that these type of opportunities don't
happen very often in free agency and
here's the thing to remember and this is
why teams used the franchise tag because
there are certain organizations out
there that understand the business
value of being able to say on March 18
we have Sun Jadeveon Clowney and he
holds up the jersey and oh by the way
the Jersey is available for purchase at
NFL shop calm and oh by the way if you
want season tickets here's the number to
call I mean and and beyond that if
you're in a market with multiple
professional sports teams and you can
disrupt their seasons by signing a guy
and the coverage and the discussion and
the attention is alternative direction
that's why guys like who was the Assante
Sam remember he got a ton of money from
the Eagles in free agency that's one of
the reasons why teams do it it generates
interest it generates money and then you
worry later whether or not it it makes
sense from a football standpoint yeah
it's always interesting going through
free agent the classes and and the teams
that sign guys like a lot of them don't
work out because a lot of times it's
either like I said a guy may be a little
on the on the wrong side of his peak fit
matters so much and what you see is a
guy have a lot of success in fit or the
players around him make him better and
then you try to plug and play him on a
worse team with them with with a worse
fit it's always interesting to see free
agency and I really I mean the best
teams win by doing everything correctly
not just free agency we always joke
about it when you win free agency you
know the Redskins how many years have
they won free agency the Jets they won
free agency last year winning free
agency does not equal winning games when
when it matters in November and December
in January
Bill Belichick has jumped into the deep
end of the free agency pool twice daily
as Thomas didn't work Stephon Gilmore
worked like a charm and I remember when
they signed Stephon Gilmore said look
they face this guy twice a year for five
years I think they know what they're
getting and what they're paying for and
why they're willing to make the
exception the good teams the smart teams
big cat they wait it out they let
everybody spend they let everybody
generate the headlines and then they go
bargain shopping for five six days into
the process and you can find great
players there and keep your salary cap
intact and have money left over to sign
your rookies and extend some of your key
players and and I think
that's the much brighter move teams like
the Colts last year with a ton of cap
space what they do they waited and I
think we're gonna see the good teams do
that again this year all right so
where's he signing up probably the Colts
probably cuz there's pressure on the
Colts to go out and spend some of that
cap money and what the heck we otherwise
go cheap let's go ahead and get him and
vamp ramp up our deep
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports